hey guys sit from PlayStation Blog here
now the destiny beta wrapped up a few
weeks ago but one of the things we
noticed a PlayStation was that a lot of
folks who have ps4s we're streaming the
game to their PS Vita's using remote
play we wanted to give you a quick crash
course on how to set everything up and
get the most out of your remote play
experience
now when you're ready to fire up destiny
on remote play it's going to pay to
familiarize yourself with the new
control scheme which Bungie thoughtfully
optimized for PS Vita so you'll hit the
PlayStation button while in remote play
mode and you'll be able to choose button
guide that's going to give you the full
control scheme and you can see here I'm
sprinting by pushing down on the d-pad
one of my favorite tweaks is the fact
that it maps the melee and the grenade
to the front touchscreen to be able to
throw a grenade by tapping the left part
of PS Vita start touchscreen or melee on
the right side of the touchscreen
so there you go that's remote play with
destiny we just want to give you guys a
quick look and definitely recommend
hooking up your ps4 using Ethernet and
also using your local Wi-Fi network to
connect to your PS Vita using remote
play now I've actually spent some time
during the destiny beta with remote play
I was actually really impressed with its
implementation so anyway destiny out
September 9th on PlayStation